♪ ♪
>> Laura: ESCAPE FROM
NEW YORK, THAT IS THE FOCUS FROM
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THERE WAS EVER A PLACE
UNITED STATES THAT STANDS AS THE
SUPREME TEST FOR LIBERALISM IT
IS NEW YORK.
AND TONIGHT WE CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY
SAY THE RESULTS ARE HORRENDOUS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THINK ABOUT IT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN CONTROL OF EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT THERE, NOT JUST IN
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
BUT IN ALBANY.
DEMOCRATS OUTNUMBERED THE
REPUBLICANS THEREBY A HUNDRED
AND 6-42.
CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE SOLELY
THE PRODUCT OF LIBERAL RULE.
CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL UP IN
EVERY EXCEPT MURDER.
44% INCREASE IN 2,022 ALONE.
WITH REPEAT OFFENDERS A HUGE
PART OF THE SPIRAL.
NOW TO ADD INSULT TO ACTUAL
INJURY.
NO GARGANTUAN BUDGET IS FILLED
WITH ALL THE UNION GIVEAWAYS
ALSO FUND HER REELECTION.
AS A "WALL STREET JOURNAL"'S
EDITORIAL BOARD POINTED OUT THE
$220 BILLION DEAL MOST EGREGIOUS
EARMARK IS $600 MILLION TO HELP
A HOMETOWN FOOTBALL TEAM THE
BUFFALO BILLS BUILD A NEW
STADIUM.
WHAT A WRETCHED DEAL FOR
TAXPAYERS.
NOW THIS PROPOSAL IS DOUBLE
FLORIDA'S BUDGET.
U.S. POPULATION IS 1,920,000,000
IT'S 21.8 MILLION.
THAT'S ALL JUST SCRATCHING THE
SURFACE OF THE CORRUPTION WERE
SEEING.
THERE'S TAX BREAKS FROM
MARIJUANA BUSINESS TAX
INCENTIVES FOR HOLLYWOOD
FILMMAKERS.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THERE IS A POSITIVE NOTE.
RESTAURANTS WILL BE ABLE TO
SERVE TO GO DRINKS FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
GREAT.
PROJECTING THE OUT DOOR PUB
CRAWL THERE FUN BUT ASSIGNED KEY
FROM FILLING NEW YORK.
THE EXTENT OF THE EXODUS HAS
BEEN SHOCKING.
BETWEEN JULY 2020 JULY OF LAST
YEAR.
MORE THAN 300,000 MOVED OUT OF
NEW YORK CITY.
ED ACCORDING TO A POLL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR NEW YORK CITY.
40% OF EMPLOYEES LIVE IN
MANHATTAN ARE THINKING OF
LEAVING.
>> SINCE THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
PAIN, APARTMENTS SEEM TO BECOME
A STAPLE ALL ACROSS FIVE
BOROUGHS.
BETWEEN RISING CRIME AND
HOMELESSNESS.
A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
NEW YORKERS MAKE OF THE CITY'S
PRIVATE SECTOR WORKFORCE THINK
IT MIGHT BE BEST TO LEAVE.
>> IS THE CITY CAN BE SAFE ARE
WE GONNA DRIFT BACK INTO
CONDITIONS WHERE WE JUST CAN'T
BE ON THE STREET OR THE SUBWAY?
>> Laura: THE STATE IS DYING.
IN 1960 NEW YORK HAD 45
ELECTORAL VOTES IN 2,024 I WILL
HAVE ONLY 28.
MEANWHILE OVER THE SAME.
FLORIDA WENT FROM TEN ELECTORAL
VOTES TO 30.
ANOTHER TOUGH ON CRIME
PRO-FREEDOM STATES LIKE FLORIDA.
AT SOME POINT WAITING FOR US THE
VOTERS WHO ARE STILL LEFT IN
NEW YORK HAS TO SAVE THEMSELVES
WERE TIRED OF THIS AND WHEN I
CANNOT TAKE IT ANYMORE.
THEY BLEW THEIR COVERT RESPONSE
WITH LONG LOCKDOWNS AND MANDATES
WE WARNED THEM NOSING TO BE A
DISASTER LED TO AN ACCELERATION
OF FAMILIES FLEEING THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
THROUGH LAST FALL IN ROME AND IN
NEW YORK CITY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
DROPPED BY 50,000.
SINCE THE START OF PANDEMIC.
THIS IS INSANE.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
NEW YORK SHOULD BE THE CREME DE
LA CREME OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT THINK ABOUT WHAT IT HAS ITS
DON'T HAVE.
VOTERS START HAVE TO WONDER HOW
DOES THE CITY KNOWN AS FINANCIAL
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD KNOWN FOR
ITS THEATER AND OPERA AND HAVE
TO SAY IT WITH BREATHTAKING
LAKES AND NATURAL RESOURCES
KNOWN FOR ITS STUNNING BEACHES
ON LONG ISLAND MYSTERY
UNIVERSITIES.
HOW ON EARTH CAN THIS PLACE BE
SO SCREWED UP HOW ON EARTH CAN
THE STATE BE IN SUCH DECLINE.
THREE WORDS, FAR LEFT DEMOCRATS.
FOR DECADES THE VOTERS THOUGHT
TO BE GOOD TO TURN GOVERNMENT
OVER THE ONE FAMILY THE CUOMO'S
WE KNOW HOW THAT WORKED OUT.
AFTER ANDREW CUOMO EMBROILED IN
SCANDAL FORCED OUT IN AUGUST.
SHE IS A COMPLETE HACK SHE WAS
IN A SHE'S DOING.
IN FACT SHE IS SO BAD THE GUY
SHE CHOSE LAST YEAR BEFORE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WAS FORCED
TO RESIGN THIS WEEK AFTER BEING
INDICTED ON BRIBERY.
>> LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WILL BE
INDICTED FOR BRIBERY.
SO UNDER THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
THIS MORNING.
>> Laura: IT'S BEEN ONE BAD
LEADER AFTER ANOTHER LATELY.
NEW YORK BECAME A LAUGHING STOCK
ONLY EGBERT de BLASIO WITH HIS
PRO-ILLEGAL ALIEN IN POLICE
AGENDA.
WHAT IS HE KNOWN FOR?
HE WAS KNOWN FOR BEING JUST LAZY
AND FOCUS ON IMPORTANT STUFF
LIKE PAINTING BLACK LIVES MATTER
IN FRONT OF TRUMP TOWER.
THE NUMERIC CAMPAIGN THOUGH IS A
MORE SENSIBLE ALTERNATIVE.
ERIC ADAMS.
>> WHAT DIRECTION IS THE CITY
HEADING AND IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AS WE SIT HERE THIS
MORNING THE MORNING AFTER A MASS
SHOOTING.
IS IT REALLY GETTING BETTER?
>> WE ORGAN TO GET BETTER.
THIS CAN BE A SAFE CITY BUT
LET'S BE CLEAR.
WE ARE DEALING WITH HISTORICAL
INEQUALITIES, HISTORICAL
ABANDONMENTS OF FEELINGS.
>> Laura: DID KNOW THAT
HISTORY EXIST BEFORE RUBY
GIULIANI BECAME MAYOR EXCUSE ME.
NOT EVERYTHING THE LEFT
COMPLAINS ABOUT NOW WAS TRUE
THEN.
AND YET HE GOT CRIME UNDER
CONTROL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT HISTORY.
IT IS ABOUT COMPETENCE.
NOW IMAGINE IF YOU MOVE TO
NEW YORK WOULD SAY, 15 YEARS AGO
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
YOU STAYED UP AND START A SMALL
BUSINESS, PLAY BY THE RULES BUT
NOW YOU'VE TEENAGERS TRAPPED IN
RUN SCHOOLS.
HE LOST OR STORED DURING THE
RIDICULOUS LOCKDOWN.
IN THIS WEEK YOU'RE AFRAID TO
RIDE THE SUBWAY.
IMAGINE BEING THAT PERSON.
NOW FRANK SINATRA SAINT SAID I
WANT TO A PART OF IT.
NEW YORK, NEW YORK.
BUT TODAY YOU'RE NOT SO MUCH
WAKING UP IN A CITY THAT DOESN'T
SLEEP YOUR WAKING UP IN A CITY
THAT DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
WITH THE GOVERNOR, THIS IS THE
TIME FOR NEW YORKERS TO MAKE A
BRAND-NE